Die zwei Sprechstunden. Hat es sich an diesem 26.04.
Okay, davon gibt es eine große Fangemeinde von diesen kleinen Ponys und Daniel ist anscheinend der Leiter einer solche Fangemeinde. Hallo Daniel. 1200 Leute? Hast du auf deiner Seite vermutlich versammelt?
Die hören alle zu, richtig.
Um Gottes Willen!
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie viel, wahrscheinlich auch weltweit gerade den Livestream im Internet mithören.
Aber dann erklär du doch mal, was für dich die Faszination an dieser Serie ist.
Die Faszination an der Serie ist für mich erstmal die ganze Fangemeinde dahinter. Denn ich glaube, ich hab noch nie im Internet, man kennt ja verschiedene Fangemeinden von, egal ob jetzt ganzen Zeichensstilen wie Anime, Manga, diese ganze Animax-Geschichte, die Cosplayer und so. Egal was man sieht im Internet, es existiert irgendwo immer so ein Wettbewerb, wer da der Beste ist und wer besser ist als der andere, wer das schönste Cosplay, also Kostüm hat. Cosplay, schätze ich, muss ich nicht erklären, oder?
Na ja, man könnte kurz sagen, das sind Leute, die sich anziehen, also wirklich so kostümieren und auch basteln, um genauso auszusehen, wie die Leute aus den Serienbüchern oder was auch immer.
Und das existiert zum Beispiel bei, es gibt, erstmal wollte ich erklären, was diese Fans der Serie My Little Pony nennen sich Bronies.
Stimmt, das hatte ich ganz vergessen.
Genau, ein Kofferwort aus Bro, also Brother, Bruder und Pony hat es auch auf Fortschreit entstanden, soweit ich informiert bin. Und in dieser Brony-Community, bei den Musikern zum Beispiel, gibt es absolut keinen Wettbewerb, wer der Beste ist. Die arbeiten alle zusammen, egal woher sie kommen. Es ist international, es ist völlig wurscht, woher man kommt, egal ob, ich weiß nicht, Australien, Deutschland, Italien, USA. Man arbeitet immer zusammen, man tauscht sich aus mit irgendwelchen Informationen. Egal Musik, Zeichnungen, es gibt auf DeviantArt unendlich viele Brony-Gruppen mit begnadeten Künstlern, die sich da wirklich ins Volk legen. Nach einer Episode, da ist ein neues Pony aufgetaucht, jetzt erst vor kurzem die letzte Folge. Da ist ein neues Pony aufgetaucht und es gibt innerhalb von zwei Stunden Bilder, die könnten, weiß ich nicht, für 1000 Euro verkauft werden, weil sie so wunderschön sind und die werden in zwei Stunden gezeichnet, superschnell und superschön. Und dass da einfach wirklich Leute sind, die wirklich was drauf haben, ein Riesentalent und völlig freundlich sind. Es gibt nicht keines, ich hab selten erlebt, dass es irgendwie was gibt, wie aus anderen Communities kennt man ja.
Das heißt aber, der Hauptreiz besteht für dich eigentlich nicht so sehr in der Serie, sondern eher in der Leute, die sich dahinter sozialisiert haben.
In der Serie auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, ich hab jede Folge viel zu oft gesehen. Ich würde sagen, man kann sie nicht zu oft sehen, aber ich hab jede Folge bestimmt mindestens zehnmal geschaut. Ich liebe diese Serie, es ist unfassbar. Es macht einfach glücklich, die zu sehen. Wie soweit ich weiß, Herr Urbach ja gesagt hat, es macht einfach happy.
Es macht einfach glücklich.
Es ist einfach schön, die Serie zu sehen. Da ist ja auch so ein gewisser Witz drin, den eben kleine Kinder vielleicht gar nicht verstehen. Das sieht man ja auch bei anderen Serien.
Es ist tatsächlich, es sind Elemente eingebaut, die irgendwie keiner versteht, die man selbst als Erwachsener erst nachschlagen muss zumindest. Ich hatte das gerade erst gehört, in der letzten Folge sind wohl in der Musik irgendwie über musikalische Tricks Hinweise auf den Plot eingebaut. Der Macher der Musik, Daniel Ingram, wenn ich mich gerade nicht täusche, ist da sehr aktiv unterwegs. Es ist nicht ganz wie bei den Simpsons, was ja jetzt direkt keine Kinderserie ist, aber es ist schon ähnlich, dass tatsächlich dann mehrere Ebenen drin sind, die man auch als Erwachsener zu schätzen weiß.
Okay, Daniel sagt, Ponys sind zum Wohlfühlen total super. Daniel, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß noch in der Fan-Community. So, ich bin ja ein bisschen erstaunt, dass beim Chaosradio heute echt die Leitungen voll sind. Das ist ja eher selten anscheinend. Gibt es da eine Übereinstimmung zwischen Nörrtum und Populärkultur? Oder ist es tatsächlich viel mehr?
Die Leute finden Ponys einfach prima.
Wir haben keine Hasse in der Leitung.
Und hoffen wir, dass das so bleibt. Aber wir haben ein paar Leute, die sagen, wo es nicht die Ponys sind, sondern die noch mal generell zur Fanfiction was sagen wollen. Zum Beispiel den Alex aus Lichtenberg. Sag mal kurz, worum geht es bei dir?
Und die anderen Adoptionen von den Leuten.
Was genau ist das?
Lord of the Weed ist eher nicht schlecht synchronisiert, aber doch sehr ins Licherliche gezogen und sehr, sehr lustig. Also wenn man auf wirklich platten Humor steht...
Ja, es ist tatsächlich ein sehr spezieller Geschmack. Ich konnte es nicht lustig finden.
Ja, keine Gemeinsamkeit. Aber die einfach wirklich nur berieseln lassen und sich den wirklich absoluten Bullshit da reinzuziehen. Und die Leute, die haben sich da wirklich Mühe gegeben, es wirklich auch sehr platt wirken zu lassen.
Du meinst, sie haben darum gekämpft, das Niveau auf ein neues Mindestmaß herabzusenken?
Absolut, absolut, nee, also wirklich jetzt der Wind pfeift durch die Bäume, wirklich alles so mit dem Mund.
Okay, sehr albern und sehr billig, was ist dann für dich der Reiz daran?
Ja, allein die Tatsache, dass sich die Leute damit auseinandergesetzt haben und versucht haben, da irgendwo nochmal eine völlig sinnlose Story eigentlich reinzubasteln. Und es hat auch sehr, sehr viele Anhänger, wie ich mitbekommen habe. Dadurch entstanden noch sehr viele Adaptionen, wie zu Star Trek und... Ja, bestes Beispiel ist hier...
Der war auf der Stitch, Buhl, Bäh...
Was war das gerade?
Ah, keine Ahnung, schieß mich durch.
Die hessische Fansynchro von Star Trek TNG, glaube ich. Meinst du das mit dem schwarzen Kaffee?
Echt, einen schwarzen Kaffee! Okay, ja, da gibt es in der Tat jede Menge Zeug. YouTube ist da, glaube ich, Ansprechpartner der Wahl.
Aber mit Ausrufezeichen absolut, ja.
Alex, hast du das selber schon mal an sowas versucht?
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich meine, wer jetzt so sagt, der hat nicht irgendwie mal zu Hause da gesessen, irgendwie im Freundeskreis und hat mal ein DVD Play auf Mute geschaltet. Und hat sich da selber eine Story so ausgedacht, der lügt.
Aha, kleine Kostprobe gefällig? Okay, Alex, trotzdem vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, gerne. So, Tina, wollte ich mal fragen, ist das denn, ich hätte jetzt vermutet, wenn es Fanfiction gibt, dass dann eigentlich die Leute sich Mühe geben, das so gut wie möglich zu machen, weil man dann so am Original dran ist. Aber sozusagen dieses, wir machen es total platt, weil wir es eh nicht können, ist das sozusagen ein Stilmittel?
Ja, man muss da so ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen Fanfiction und Spoof. Also das, was der Alex auch gerade so ein bisschen erzählt hat, geht ein bisschen in die Richtung Spoof, denke ich mal. Da wird ein Original genommen und es wird verändert, es wird persifliert, es wird damit gespielt und es wird tatsächlich so ein bisschen durch den Kakao gezogen. Spoof findet man zum Beispiel auch in der Pornografie ganz, ganz vermehrt. Da werden irgendwie populär erfolgreiche Filme und Bücher genommen und durch so eine Pornomangel gedreht. Und Fanfiction ist aber tatsächlich sehr ernst gemeint. Also diese Fan-Community, die bezeichnen sich selber wirklich als Fans. Also die finden das gut, diesen Kanon und diese Welt dieser Figuren. Und die tauchen da so sehr drin ein und schreiben das halt weiter. Also das ist sehr ernsthaft gemeint.
Okay, das heißt du würdest dieses Spoof dann rausnehmen daraus?
Es gibt auch Fans-Boosts, also ich glaube, es war eine hessische, ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Dialekt nie so richtig zuordnen können. Aber es gibt ja diese deutsche Synchro von Star Trek Next Generation. Die ist auch sehr witzig, das ist auch fanbasiert und fangemacht, aber es geht nicht in Richtung Fanfiction, weil es die Stories nicht ernsthaft weiterentwickelt. Also es ist mehr so eine Persiflage.
Das sagst du jetzt, aber wer weiß, was sich für Bedeutungen dahinter verstecken. Ich meine selbst bunte Ponys, aber egal.
Siegerländerplatt lese ich gerade. Es ist Siegerländerplatt, sagt Philipp Stefan. Der muss es hoffentlich wissen.
Alles klar, wenn ihr noch selber ein Beispiel habt oder euch mal versucht habt und das mal hier zum Besten vorgehen wollt, gerne 0331 70 97 110. Wir kehren zurück zu den Ponys. Ludwig aus Bitburg. Hallo Ludwig. Was ist deine Faszination an den kleinen bunten Pferden?
Ach ja, was ist meine Faszination? Diese Ponys haben mein Leben zum Positiven verändert. Also ich, ja wie krieg ich es aus? Es war so, dass ich, ich bin jetzt seit ungefähr ein halbes oder Jahr in der Brony-Gemeinde und bin auch in der größten deutschen Brony-Gemeinde, wovor uns auch der Daniel schon angerufen hat. Und bin auch wirklich stolzes Mitglied davon. Und ja, ich bin halt aus mir selbst rausgekommen. Ich war früher, ich sag mal, ein bisschen in mich gekehrt. Ich hatte Angst auf andere Leute zuzugehen und war auch nicht wirklich selbstbewusst. Aber naja, nachdem ich dann halt angefangen hab, diese Ponys zu gucken, habe ich halt gemerkt, ich kann mich eigentlich so nehmen, wie ich bin. Durch diese ganzen Moralen, die am Ende der Folge gebracht werden, wie vorhin schon erwähnt wurde. Ja, und das macht mich halt richtig stolz, ein Teil davon zu sein.
Aber wir haben ja auch schon lange gehört, dass diese Moraldinger eher platt waren. Inwiefern...
Nein, nein, nein, nicht platt. Simple, hab ich gesagt. Das ist was anderes.
Okay, simpel.
Aber das heißt ja nicht weniger wahr, genau.
Ja, aber nur weil die simpel sind, heißt es ja nicht direkt, dass sie dadurch weniger gut sind. Das sagt doch wer. Weil die ganzen Fabeln alle, die haben ja auch eine simple Moralwende und trotzdem werden sie immer wieder Kindern als Beispiel erklärt.
Ja, sehr blutig bei Grim in der Tat.
Da sind die Ponys nicht ganz so blutig, zumindest nicht im Kanan.
Und das ist halt genau dasselbe, was ich dann halt so sehe. Diese Moral ist zwar einfach, aber sie hat bei mir trotzdem das Bezweck.
War es denn der Erkenntnisgewinn durchs Schauen der Serie? Oder war es auch die soziale Kommunikation mit anderen Leuten, die auch, wie heißt es, Bronys waren?
Das kann ich so gar nicht direkt beantworten. Ich glaube, am Anfang war es einfach so diese Neugierd dadurch, das Leben so, ich sage jetzt mal, neu zu entdecken, sage ich jetzt mal ausgedrückt, aber im Endeffekt war es dann auch, dass wir den anderen Leuten reden, auf andere Leute zugehen, einfach das Leben anfangen neu zu geließen auf diese Art und Weise. Einfach die kleinen Dinge genießen und wie es halt da immer wieder beschrieben wird, sage ich jetzt mal.
Okay, würdest du das anderen Leuten auch empfehlen? Guck dich das mal an, weil da kann man Erkenntnis rausziehen.
Also empfehlen würde ich auf jeden Fall, ich meine, also mich hat das dazu gebracht, diesen Thema Fanfiction, ich übersetze die Englischen sehr gerne auf Deutsch und davon habe ich…
Hoffentlich besser als die offiziellen Übersetzungen.
Bitte?
Ja, also ich habe jetzt immer nur ein gutes Feedback auf DeviantArt bekommen. Und also ich habe My Little Dashie, das ist die bekannteste, einer der bekanntesten Fanfics, die ist wirklich sehr traurig, 26 Seiten stark. Die habe ich übersetzt, einfach um die Geschichte zu teilen. Und ich wollte auch keine Gegenleistung haben, einfach aus Freude, weil mir einer der anderen schon ein Danke genug war.
Du hast das übersetzt, bist du aber nicht in Versuchen gekommen, dich auch mal selber zu versuchen?
Ja, also ein Freund hat mich mal zu einem Brainstorming einer Fanfiction überredet, aber das Problem ist einfach, ich prokrastiniere dann sehr viel und im Endeffekt wird das dann einfach nie wirklich was.
Bevor wir mit der Geschichte anfangen, gucken wir noch eine Folge My Little Pony.
Bitte?
Bevor wir mit der Geschichte anfangen, guck dir dann noch eine Folge My Little Pony, oder wie?
Nö, wir haben die immer zusammen live im Stream angeschaut damals. Jetzt kamen wir leider letzten Wochenende der Staffelfinale. Davor haben wir uns immer im Teamspeak getroffen bzw. im Skype, haben ein bisschen vor der Folge gequatscht, was könnte passieren, wie könnte es ausgehen. Und dann während der Folge haben wir in den Werbepausen immer die letzte Szene besprochen und die letzte Stunde danach haben wir dann halt über die ganze Folge geredet und diskutiert und haben uns gefreut darüber.
Also, die Zuschauer zu Hause sehen das jetzt nicht, aber ich glaube, Markus fällt gleich vor den Konzernfisch. Das ist eine sehr glückliche, mach ihn sehr glücklich.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall fasziniert davon. Also ich bin das immer wieder, weil gerade als Journalist beschäftigt man sich immer wieder mit Themen und ich bin immer wieder fasziniert, dass es egal worum es geht, es gibt diese tiefe Lust daran, etwas wirklich zu zelebrieren. Und das fand ich immer großartig. Ludwig, dir auf jeden Fall viel Spaß noch dabei. So, jetzt ist gerade hinter den Kulissen drüber geredet worden, dass es ja in dieser Fanfiction-Anteilung auch die dunkleren Kapitel gibt. Tina? Ich habe ja etwas von Horror und Slasher irgendwie jetzt im Hinterkopf. Gibt es sowas für die kleinen süßen Ponys etwa auch?
Ja, ich hab da eine, die ist, das ist die bekannteste, die kennt wohl auch die Pony-Gemeinde. Die ist 1189 Seiten lang, zumindest jetzt hier. Ja, die hat mehrere Kapitel, also mehrere im Sinne von, ich glaube 20, 30 oder so. Die heißt Fallout Equestria. Die müssten eigentlich alle kennen, die sich so ein bisschen mit My Little Pony und Slashfiction beschäftigen. Soll ich mal einen Absatz vorlesen?
Kannst du kurz noch für die anderen sozusagen erklären, worum es da geht?
Das spielt in einer postapokalyptischen Welt. Und zwar gab es irgendwie, das hat sie auch erklärt, in der Einleitung, da ging es irgendwie darum, dass die Magie überhand nahm und dann haben sie sich alle gestritten. Und dann gab es irgendwie einen riesen radioaktiven Clash. Und es gab jedenfalls irgendwie eine Zerstörung von Equestria. Also so ganz klassischer postapokalyptischer Plot.
Also dazu müssen wir kurz sagen, Equestria ist die Welt, in der die Ponys leben. Kenterlott ist die Hauptstadt, das haben wir noch nicht richtig eingeführt.
Genau, Ponyville ist irgendwie das Dorf, wo die da alle rumbringen. Und jetzt ist es so, es gibt unterirdische Bunker, die heißen Stables, also Ställe. Und in diesen Ställen leben jetzt diese Ponys sozusagen unterirdisch, haben noch nie mehr das Sonnenlicht gesehen, weil oben gibt es ja offensichtlich nichts. Das ist die Geschichte eines dieser Ponys. Dieses Pony hat auch einen Namen, habe ich jetzt vergessen. Oh Gott, habe ich vergessen. Und das ist kein so besonders spezielles Pony, also das fühlt sich nicht so besonders special. Und das geht dann auf einmal aus diesen Stables raus in diese postapokalyptische Welt, die bevölkert ist von auch Ponys, aber diese Ponys sind dem nicht so wohl gesinnt. Das ist mehr so The Road mit Ponys. Ja, nicht Mutanten, aber so ein bisschen so. Ja, wir müssen überleben und deswegen müssen wir euch jetzt leider tippen und vorher und so. Also, das ist alles zu erwachsen.
Okay, also Mutantenponys gibt es ja nicht, da muss ich wohl selber mal was schreiben und du kriegst uns jetzt einen kleinen Absatz daraus vor.
Genau, das ist allerdings auf Englisch. Ich hoffe, das ist kein Problem. Auf Deutsch habe ich das nicht gefunden. Ich sah kaum die Vorleger des Radar-Pony am Ende des Türschirms. Mit einem zweiten Gedanken levitierte ich das Tisch, damit es eine Barrikade auf der unteren Hälfte des Türschirms geformt hat und nach hinten gerannt hat. Die Geschichte ist tatsächlich relativ, also ich fand die sehr spannend. Ich bin jetzt irgendwie auf Seite, ich glaube 56 von 1189. Die ist lesbar, die ist auch sehr spannend und sie ist ziemlich gruselig. Also ich fand sie ziemlich gruselig. Also da werden ständig Ponys gekillt.
Gut, so ich möchte natürlich auch noch mal über die, also über Kritiken sozusagen nachher noch mal sprechen an der Serie, die es möglicherweise gibt. Jetzt noch mal ein kleiner Ausflug woanders hin. Stella aus Berlin hat angerufen und ist in Fanfiction in einem anderen Bereich unterwegs. Hallo Stella.
Hallo. Also Fanfiction an sich schreib ich jetzt selber nicht, aber ich denk mal, wenn man Anime guckt, Manga liest, dann stößt man auch unweigerlich darauf. Und das ist denke ich mal meistens auch Slashfiction. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit man darüber jetzt hier so großartig reden kann.
Um die Uhrzeit. Was genau planst du?
Explizite Sexualakte beschreiben?
Nein. Nein. Es gibt ja eigentlich so einen großen, das nennt sich ja Dojinshi. Das sind ja praktisch bei Animefiguren, lässt sich ja auch recht einfach zeichnen, weil das eben von vornherein schon gezeichnet ist und eben kein echten Menschen sind. Und das ist eben so, dass dann bei den populären Serien dann auch immer in großen Massen so was rauskommt und sich auch recht schnell im Internet finden lässt. Und das ist eigentlich, also soweit ich weiß, dass 90 Prozent davon werden wohl sexuell sein, also Slashfiction. Aber...
Und das findest du besonders faszinierend? Oder wie kommst du darauf, deswegen hier anzurufen?
Nein, nein, das ist an sich nicht faszinierend. Aber worauf ich hinausfahre, ist, dass es wirklich dabei teilweise, was man auch gar nicht erwartet, wirklich gute Geschichten gibt. Ich kann jetzt wohl schlecht Beispiele nennen. Aber eben da, wo man es auch gar nicht erwartet, gibt es gute Geschichten. Aber das ist eigentlich nur der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist, dass es eben das, was nicht Slashfiction ist, das kommt eher seltener vor. Aber wenn ich mal ein Beispiel nennen kann, ich glaube im Winter war das, da ist ein Anima rausgekommen, der hieß Goaty Crown. Und da haben Leute einfach sich hingesetzt und haben den Praktische umgeschrieben, dass er ein Spiel werden könnte. Sie haben da das System aufgeschrieben, wie es funktionieren könnte. Und wenn sich jetzt jemand noch bereit erklären würde, das zu machen, dann könnte man darauf schon ein Spiel programmieren. Es ging also.
Ah, du suchst jetzt hier Leute, oder?
Nein, nein, das wollte ich nur mal erzählen. Und jetzt frage ich mich, kennt ihr Katawashoujo? Ihr hattet ja vorhin auch über Fortschreien geredet. Und es hat ja auch da angefangen das Projekt. Das ist praktisch auch ein Spiel. Da haben wir glaube ich vier oder fünf Jahre dran gesessen.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe davon schon mal gehört, aber ich bin nicht tief drin.
Okay, Stella, das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich eine völlig neue Baustelle. Ich würde folgendes vorschlagen. Es gibt vom Chaos Computer Club betrieben ein Wiki zu dieser Sendung. Da kann man also Dinge reinschreiben. Wie wäre es, wenn du dorthin gehst und diese ganzen Punkte einmal aufschreibst, dann können Leute, die das interessiert, das nochmal nachschlagen. Chaosradio.de ist die Domain und dann einfach da auf Wiki klicken und dann das da eintragen. Möglicherweise findet sich dann auch noch ein Spieleprogrammierer. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß noch. So, ich bin ein bisschen überfallen von der ganzen, seine große Welt tut sich auf. Ich möchte jetzt jetzt nochmal kurz fragen, wir hatten es im Vorbereitung zur Sendung kurz irgendwie sexistische Tendenzen bei den Ponys. Kann man das so sagen oder ist das zu hart für eine so weiche Serie?
Na, das kann man schon sagen. Also alle Hauptfiguren sind weiblich. Es gibt sehr wenig männliche Figuren. Das ist auch einer der faszinierenden Punkte, warum sich sehr viele, also die Bronikultur ja hauptsächlich männlich ist, obwohl eigentlich kaum eine Figur weiblich männlich ist. Genau, die männlichen Figuren, die vorkommen, dürfen so Dinge tun wie Kutschen ziehen. Das muss man sich mal bildlich vorstellen. Also das ist halt eine Pferdekutsche, gezogen von Ponys, in der ein Pony sitzt. Und die Ziehpferde dürfen dann Männer sein. Männliche Ponys dürfen Bedienung im Restaurant sein. Der Süßigkeiten-Laden wird von einem Ehepaar betrieben. Da kommt doch also nochmal ein Mann vor. Und die anderen Männer... Ach ja, genau. Es gibt in der Schulklasse, es gibt also in der Serie eine Schulklasse, da sind tatsächlich zwei Jungs drin. Das sind aber mehr so Dösbattel, die halt nichts auf die Reihe kriegen und deswegen dauernd in Probleme geraten, weil sie halt zu blöd sind. Und dann kommt natürlich noch der große Bruder von Applejack, der kommt in ungefähr der Hälfte der Folgen vor, sagt, hat aber glaube ich nur in einer Folge eine längere Sprechrolle. Er sagt in allen anderen Folgen so, ist quasi ein Running-Gag, sagt er immer nur Jupp oder Nope. Das ist sehr einsilbig dargestellt, die männlichen Figuren der Serie. Erst im Staffelfinale und alle Leute, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, können jetzt vielleicht mal kurz, keine Ahnung, müssen jetzt Pause machen und dann erst die Folge gucken. Im Staffelfinale kommt dann tatsächlich eine ausnahmslos positiv und sehr breit dargestellte männliche Figur vor, die allerdings per quasi nachträglich eingebaut wurde. Also die wird halt dargestellt, als war schon immer da, wurde aber noch nie auch nur mit einer Silbe erwähnt bisher. Ist aber tatsächlich eine sehr starke, positiv dargestellte männliche Figur.
Jetzt ist das ja, wenn man sagt, okay, wenn man sich jetzt als die über 20-jährigen jungen Männer sich diese Serien angucken, dann ist das möglicherweise nicht schlimm, weil die unter Umständen reflektiert genug sind oder werden. Aber wenn das jetzt das Zielpublikum sechsjährige Mädchen sind, ist das dann schon was, wo man sagen könnte, es ist eigentlich nicht so großartig, weil die dann damit sozialisiert werden, dass es diese Geschlechtertrennung gibt?
Ah, unklar, in die Diskussion würde ich mich ungern verrennen.
Okay.
Also was auf jeden Fall auffällig ist, ist, dass im Bereich dazwischen mit so Teenagern, also wie gesagt, ich hatte ja schon mal dieses Teen's Reactor erwähnt, dass es da, also dass da die Reaktion hauptsächlich auch sehr stark darauf abzielen, dass also ein Teenager-Mann, ein junger Mann, der vielleicht in seiner Sexualität noch nicht so gefestigt ist, das doch dann mit sehr stark, sehr stark ablehnen muss, um nicht als scharfer Außenhund zu erscheinen.
Wobei ja My Little Pony tatsächlich als Aspekt von Performing Gender, also wenn wir jetzt über die E-Bronies reden, die männliche Zielgruppe, wenn sich jemand offen zu My Little Pony bekennt, dann ist das auf jeden Fall auch so ein Bekenntnis zu eben was niedlichem, was kleinem, etwas, was irgendwie als aus dem Feminin-Gender-Spektrum kommend so Stereotyp bekannt ist. Und das finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Weil es dann halt so ein bisschen diese Auflösung dieser starren Rollenbilder, ja. Ich bin, ich kann durchaus irgendwie ein selbstidentifizierter männlicher Mann sein mit irgendwie mit männlichen Vorlieben und ich gucke trotzdem kleine Ponys.
Ja, das finde ich auch, das fasziniert mich auch. Also ich bin da auch sehr kurz erst quasi damit mit mir im Reimen und so dermaßen nach außen auftretend.
Dass man beobachtet es also auch sich selbst, dass man eigentlich denkt, man ist reflektiert und erwachsen und hat natürlich kein Problem, aber dann stellt man fest, da ist doch diese Barriere irgendwie, oder wie ist dir das ergangen? Also dass du sagen, dass du dich überlegt hast, gebe ich das jetzt zu oder nicht?
So in etwa ja, also dass ich jetzt quasi in meiner Männlichkeit gefässigt bin, dass das geht.
Interessant, wofür die kleinen Ponys alle gut sein können. Wir sprechen gleich noch eine halbe Stunde drüber. Vorher machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Genau, das war der Vorspann für die Leute, die es wissen. Das war tatsächlich die zweite Staffel. Ich glaube, da gibt es einen kleinen Unterschied in den musikalischen Darbietungen.
Herzlich willkommen. Ihr seid beim Chaosradio in Blue Moon auf Ritz und wir sprechen heute über Ponys. Tatsächlich sprechen wir heute über Fanfiction, über einen Teil der Nerdkultur und das erklärt am Beispiel der Serie My Little Pony, Friendship is Magic. Oh mein Gott, wo sind wir nur gelandet. Tatsächlich rufen heute selten viele Leute an beim Chaosradio, weil es um diese komische Fernsehserie geht. Ich weiß nicht genau...
Habe ich dir doch gesagt, dass Phänom sehr viele Leute mobilisieren können.
Das sind diese 1200 Leute der Fanclubs, die wir hier im Chaosradio...
Ich glaube nicht alle, aber einige zumindest, ja.
Na gut, dann nehmen wir gleich nochmal den Luca mit dazu.
Ja, die Frage habe ich mich auch schon ausgestellt. Also ich habe zum ersten Mal auf YouTube gesehen, das ist die erste Folge, das war auf Deutsch übrigens.
Oh ja, ganz schlimm.
Ja, so schlimm war es auch wieder nicht.
Also der Vorspann, ich fragte wozu Freundschaft gut sein kann, doch dann botet ihr die Freundschaft mir an.
Oh, das ist ja schon dramatikalisch irgendwie.
Ja, reim dich oder ich feste dich. Okay, ja, Entschuldigung, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen, rede weiter.
Ich mach nichts. Ja, ich hab's angeschaut erstmal und dann dachte ich, Scheiße, wieso kann ich das toll finden? Ich fand's wirklich gut. Ich fand's gut, wusste aber nicht wieso. Hab dann, nach ein paar Tagen hab ich aus Langeweile, ich hatte echt keine Lust gehabt, irgendwas zu machen, einfach mal die erste Staffel komplett am Stück angeschaut, das war neun Stunden, übrigens, am Stück durch und dann, ich war einfach baff.
Okay, hast du dich dann auch mal mit Fanfiction beschäftigt?
Ich wollte einmal eins schreiben, aber ich hab's dann aufgegeben, bevor es zwar begonnen hat und dann gelesen hab ich noch nicht, aber ich hol's immer mal nach.
Und worum sollte das gehen, was du schreiben wolltest?
Das sag ich lieber nicht.
Oh, Luca, na gut, das ist ein ungeschriebenes Werk. Aber wenn du's fertig hast, sagst du Bescheid, ja?
Wir lesen's dann im Radio vor.
Ich glaube, die lassen uns nach dieser Sendung nicht wieder rein.
Ich hab übrigens jetzt Slashfiction zu My Little Pony gefunden, falls ihr daran noch Interesse habt.
Machen wir vielleicht zum Abschluss der Sendung. Alles klar. So, Luca, würdest du anderen Leuten empfehlen, My Little Pony zu einen Start zu bringen?
Ich hab so einen Versuch von meinen Freunden und na, es ging gar nicht.
Was war die Reaktion?
Na ja, mein Kostän hat gesagt, du schaust dir eine Sendung an mit Ponys. Er hat ganz übrigens laut gesagt, meine Freunde, die haben gesagt, nee, vergiss es. Braucht gar nicht, damit wir erst ankommen, ne?
Okay, hast du dann, wir haben ja schon ein paar Leute hier am Telefon gehabt, die sagen, eine riesen Community, total geil, hast du dich dann noch miteinander zusammengetan, die das auch großartig finden?
Wie mein ich das jetzt?
Na irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Internetfonds, Kontakte geknüpft, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht.
Ja, ich war auch ein Fan, das war mal in Frankfurt.
Ah, gab es auch Verkleidete? Da gibt es aber noch was nachzuholen.
Ich persönlich war ja, ich fand das ja auf dem letzten Chaos Communication-Kongress sehr schön, da hatten sich dann auch spontan quasi Leute auf dem Flur zusammengefunden, haben einen der Fernseher gekapert und darauf eine Folge geguckt. Ich bin ja auch so ein Haarfärbe-Fan und hatte mir ja auch für den Kongress passend meine Haare gefärbt in Twilight-Sparkle-Manier. Ich hatte auch das passende Horn dazu mit einem 3D-Drucker ausgedruckt und mir ein T-Shirt zur Hand gemacht. Also nicht vollständig Cosplay, aber in die richtige Richtung geht.
Also Leute, lasst euch eure Zunge zergehen, ja? The Pinnacle of Technical Evolution, ein 3D-Drucker, wird dazu benutzt, dass Leute sich Hörner ausdrucken um...
Ja, Selbstrealisation, hey!
Was genau heißt das?
Naja, sich selber verwirklichen können, mit Technik, ist doch prima.
Und ausgelöst durch eine kleine Fernseher. Luca, dir viel Spaß damit noch.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Bis dann, tschüss. So, dann haben wir noch den Patrick, ebenfalls ein Fan. Patrick?
Ja, hallo. Ja, ich hab das ganze Thema eben bei uns im Forum mitbekommen. Ein Kollege hat mir das gesagt, dass ihr da heute über das Thema redet. Und da wollte ich einfach mal auch mich dazu äußern. Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ich kann es eigentlich jedem nur empfehlen, der wirklich gute Zeichentrickserien, sich auch alte Zeichentrickserien gern angeguckt hat. My Little Pony ist einfach wirklich gemacht wie die älteren Zeichentrickserien, die ich aus meiner Kindheit auch kenne. Es ist wirklich eine tolle Sache. Die Folgen sind komplett gut durchdacht und auch wunderbar gezeichnet. Und ich kann es eigentlich nur wirklich jedem empfehlen, es selber mal anzugucken, eventuell als Anlaufadresse auch mal bronis.de zu gehen. Das ist glaub ich deutschlandweit auch die größte Internet-Community. Ich bin da selber angemeldet. Wir haben knapp 1.700 User dort.
Patrick, ist denn das Faszinierende für dich, die Serie hat man immer geguckt, ist das dann auch die Leute, die dazugehören?
Es ist auch rein vom Fandom her eins der stärkst vertretenen, die ich im Internet bis jetzt selber miterlebt habe. Und es ist ja wirklich so, wenn man sich mit den Leuten kurzschließt, man kann sich jeden Abend im TS mit denen unterhalten, sie sind eigentlich immer da, wenn man wirklich mal ein Problem hat. Die helfen auch einem in anderen Formen oder Fandoms, habe ich schon erlebt. Die lassen einen dann trotzdem einfach hängen. Die sagen halt, ja, Pech für dich. Aber da ist wirklich ein Zusammenhalt da. Also die Serie schweißt wirklich Leute zusammen.
Hast du denn sich selber schon mal an Fanfiction probiert?
Nein, ich bin aber auf Bronies.de leidenschaftlich RPG-Schreiber.
Du musst kurz die drei Buchstaben erläutern.
Das sind RPGs und ich bin in einem zum Beispiel vertreten. Das heißt Luna Republic. Da geht es mehr um Kriegsszenario, wo das Ganze abspielt.
Das ist ein RPG-Role-Playing-Game?
Also sie sagen, ihr versetzt euch in die Rolle eines Ponys und in die Rolle eines Ponys und spielt dann sozusagen Geschichten aus dieser Welt nach. Per Text.
Wir schreiben unsere eigenen, komplett eigene Ideen und alles werden einfließen gelassen. Es ist einfach eine wunderbare Sache zum sehen, wie Leute dann auf einzelne Aktionen, die man selber macht, reagieren. Man kann einfach wirklich eine schöne Geschichte dann auch daraus zusammenfassen.
Fanfiction The Next Step quasi. Patrick, die viel Spaß noch damit. Kann man das, Tina, doch dazu zählen, zu Fanfiction? Oder ist das dann schon nochmal was ganz anderes Neues?
Aus deinem Universitätsumfeld?
Das gehört da auf jeden Fall mit rein. Das ist halt kollaboratives Fanfiction schreiben. Das ist nochmal, das ist lustig. Das ist The Next Step. Normalerweise hat man ganz klare Rollenverteilung. Es gibt den Autor der Fanfiction-Geschichte. Dann gibt es noch den Leser, also den Korrekturleser und nochmal den Kommentator sozusagen, Beta-Reader. Das ist so eine Rollenverteilung in der Fanfiction-Gemeinde. Das wird da jetzt so ein bisschen aufgehoben und durch kollaboratives Schreiben ersetzt. Das finde ich aber super.
Was wir heute auch noch alles lernen. So, dann haben wir noch den Martin. Ja, hallo. Auch ein Pony-Fan. Warum?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe, wie gesagt, die Bilder im Internet überall gesehen und damals aus Interesse halt einfach mal geguckt, was steckt denn dahinter. Und ja, angefangen bei Folge 1. Und ja, ich konnte einfach nicht mehr aufhören.
Und hast du dich auch mal selber an Fan-Faction probiert?
Na ja, ich habe mich mal dran probiert, aber ist nicht so gut geworden, sage ich mal.
Warum nicht? Woran ist es gescheitert?
Ich bin nicht so der Schreiberling, sage ich mal. Und ja, es war halt, wie soll ich sagen, mehr so auf Erotik bezogen, als aber eher in Comedy abgedriftet ist.
Slashfiction, wir haben einen Slashfiction-Schreiber am Telefon. Hast du es mal jemanden zu lesen gegeben, oder hast du dann selber entschieden, so, ne, ne, das geht nicht?
Naja, ich hab's mal hier meinen, ja, Leuten, mit denen man so im Teamspeak oder auf Facebook so in Kontakt ist, ja, vorgestellt. Die fanden es mehr lustig, zum Teil auch, ja, weiß ich nicht, von der Ausdrucksweise ein bisschen hart, ja, aber es war mehr...
Okay, da müsste also nochmal dran gefeilt werden, entnehme ich dem? Hast du denn, hast du schon gute Fanfiction gelesen?
Gelesen, ja, so My Little Dashie, die Klassiker, ja, und muss sagen, My Little Dashie kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Es ist eine ziemlich traurige Geschichte.
Oh, okay, kann man's auch merken. Martin, vielen Dank. Und viel Spaß noch. Bis dann. Tschüss. So, jetzt haben wir fast schon zwei Stunden über My Little Pony geredet. Gibt es irgendwas, was wir noch vergessen haben?
Na, was man auf jeden Fall noch mal kurz anreißen kann. Viele Leute haben vielleicht sogar schon mal was von den Ponys gehört, auch wenn sie es nicht aktiv mitgekriegt haben. Denn eines der Lieblingsthemen der Berichterstattung über die Piratenpartei, zumindest in Berlin, war ja immer die Ponytime. Es gibt nämlich auch unter den Piraten viele, zumindest Fans der Serie, wenn vielleicht nicht auch gleich voll ausgewachsene Ponys, aber Leute, die es nicht hassen. Und sie haben in die Geschäftsordnung der Berliner Piratenpartei, zumindest, weiß nicht, ob es bei der Bundespiratenpartei auch so ist, haben sie mehr oder weniger reingeschmuggelt einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag auf Ponytime. Das ist eine sehr lustige Geschichte, die sie dann auch immer gerne erzählen, so quasi so morgens, noch nicht alle da und noch nicht ganz wach, das ist noch nicht so richtig, worüber abgestimmt wird und da wird halt quasi dieser Geschäftsordnungsantrag, die wird halt dann quasi aufgenommen. Und seitdem gibt es bei der Berliner Piratenfraktion in der Geschäftsordnung einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag auf Ponytime. Das läuft dann so ab, dass jeder das beantragen kann, Ponytime beantragen kann. Die Versammlungsleitung sucht dann eine, der Grund dafür ist, wenn es gerade zu hitzig hergeht, zu heiß hergeht in der Diskussion, wenn die Gemüter erregt sind, wenn keiner mehr auf den anderen hört, dann kann man Ponytime beantragen. Die Versammlungsleitung sucht dann eine passende Folge raus. Wie gesagt, die haben ja alle jeweils eine dedizierte Moral. Ich glaube, es gibt kein ordentliches Mapping. Dazu muss man vielleicht nochmal aufrufen, so eine Liste von Moral zu Folge. Aber wenn man sie gesehen hat, kann man das vielleicht einigermaßen aus dem Kopf machen. Wird dann also eine Folge rausgesucht, abgespielt und in der Zeit beruhigen sich die Gemüter dann hoffentlich wieder.
Okay, also man muss dazu sagen, das ist jetzt nicht nur der Scherz, der da gemacht wurde, sondern es ist tatsächlich sagen, in dem, also in dieser Geschäftsordnung, in der Partei...
Es ist in der Geschäftsordnung drin und wurde schon zweimal, glaube ich, angewendet.
Bestimmt nur in Berlin. In Bayern gibt es das sicherlich nicht.
Ja, ich glaube in Berlin und bundesweit. Aber ich bin mir bei bundesweit nicht sicher. Bei Berlin weiß ich es relativ genau. Sie schreiben auch, man darf es da natürlich nicht übermäßig anwenden, sondern gezielt und mit Maßen. Aber ja, es scheint wohl zu funktionieren.
Das ist halt offiziell.
Das ist allen anderen Parteien zu empfehlen.
Wolltest du noch die Geschichte mit dem fehlenden Klinkenkabel erzählen?
Es gab dann tatsächlich wohl mal auf einer Versammlung, diesmal einer Bundesversammlung, glaube ich, hat jemand einen Antrag auf Ponytime gestellt. Ich habe das auch nur indirekt mitgekriegt. Und da war die Versammlungsleitung nicht darauf vorbereitet, hatte also kein Klinkenkabel in ihrem Laptop drin. Sie haben also die erste Folge abgespielt auf dem Beamer. Und dann mussten zwei Leute, Lapentin und Fou, glaube ich, Handmikrofon in der Hand und haben dann mehr oder weniger frei, vielleicht nicht richtig synchronisiert, aber doch sehr frei, dazu gesprochen, was gerade auf dem Bildschirm passiert. Und es war ein großer Spaß für alle, auch auf YouTube zu sehen.
Gibt es davon eine Aufnahme?
Es gibt eine Aufnahme.
Sehr schön. Bitte liebe Hörer, es gibt ein Wiki zum Chaosradio. Tragt bald den Link ein, ich möchte mir das auch gerne angucken. Ponys, nicht endwollende Geschichte.
Ja genau, wenn man schon bei Links ist, kann man dann später noch verlinken, wenn ihr mehr über Ponys erfahren wollt. Ich persönlich bin mir mehr so mit den amerikanischen Ressourcen vertraut. Also von diesen Deutschen höre ich jetzt doch fast zum ersten Mal. Im amerikanischen Sprachraum ist also ein großes Blog Equestria Daily. Also Equestria hatten wir ja schon, war das Land. Dazu gibt es dann auch ein IRC-Server, ein IRC-Netzwerk, Canternet mit einem eigenen Kanal, Equestria Daily, wo sich dann halt Leute treffen können und reden können. Bronys treffen können und reden können. Es gibt wichtige Ressourcen bei Wikia. Also Wikia, ich weiß nicht, wer das Projekt kennt. Das ist quasi so eine Art themenspezifische Wikipedia. Also kann jeder ein Wiki einrichten zu einem bestimmten Thema. Und da gibt es halt vor allen Dingen zu Fankulturen. Also Lost ist ganz groß gewesen. Lost, Battlestar Galactica und so weiter. Da gibt es dann also eigene Wikis und auch zu My Little Pony. mlpwikia.com Und was mich halt, als ich es zum ersten Mal gesehen habe, tatsächlich sehr... Na, ich will jetzt nicht überrascht sagen, aber doch sehr... Ja, doch überrascht hat. War My Little Wiki dort nett, glaube ich. Das ist dann also eine Auflistung nicht zu dieser Zeichensrickserie, sondern zu dem My Little Pony Universum allgemein, also zu den Plastikfiguren seit den 80ern. Und dort gibt es, wie gesagt, auch diese Liste mit den 1000 oder so Ponys oder 2000 mit Fotos und allem Drum und Dran, identifizierenden Merkmal. Da kann man sich also, wenn man einen Pony gefunden hat, gucken, welches es ist.
Ja, da haben wir schon stundenlang nach diesem einen doofen Pony gesucht.
Genau, wenn man mal ein Bild irgendwo findet von einem tatsächlich existierenden Plastikpony, will man es natürlich identifiziert haben.
Sehr schön, jetzt wollte ich gerade noch was fragen. Ach so, gebeten worden hier im Chat, es gibt wohl einen Podcast hier in Deutschland?
Es gibt mehrere. Wenn ich gehört habe, habe ich zuletzt den Ponytime Podcast. Auch wenn ich hier mal als Experte genannt wurde, gegen Gerjad, kann ich da jetzt nicht so richtig anstinken. Das ist also auch sehr ausführlich und lehrreich, wenn man mehr über das Universum und die Hintergründe und die Macher erfahren möchte. Das gibt es auch im englischen, das ist dann Bronyville, also quasi der Hauptpodcast dazu, mit ganz vielen Episoden und furchtbar langen Episoden, die wahrscheinlich dann alles in aller Ausführlichkeit erklären.
Okay, falls ihr noch nicht genug davon bekommen könnt. So rum, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit einer neuen Staffel? Ich habe jetzt gehört, es gibt zwei, die laufen gerade.
Genau, die Staffelfinale war letztes Wochenende, wenn ich mich gerade nicht täusche. Es wird im September wieder neue Folgen geben. Wir warten also jetzt alle gespannt darauf. Vielleicht gibt es in der Zwischenzeit mehr Fanfiction, wer weiß.
Können wir sehen. Tina, noch die eher allgemeinere Frage, jetzt gar nicht auf Ponys bezogen. Gibt es im Bereich der Fanfiction etwas in die Zukunft geblickt, was da möglicherweise eine größere Rolle spielen würde? Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel gehört, da gibt es zum ersten Mal Zusammenarbeit zwischen Firmen, die ein Massive Multiplayer Online Role-Playing Game machen wollen und dazu eine Fernsehserie drehen. Gibt es so Kollaborations-Dinge, die ihren Weg dann nach ganz oben schaffen? Sag ich mal, gibt es da Aufsichten, dass sowas in Zukunft eine größere Rolle spielen wird?
Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, bestimmt. Also da die partizipative Natur des Internets ja immer wichtiger wird, auch im Reallife und diese Grenzen einfach auch viel mehr verschwimmen, ist Fan-Kultur einfach etwas, was man nicht so richtig ignorieren mehr kann. Und wie wir auch gehört haben, es gibt richtig gute Fan-geschriebene Geschichten, und fantastische Communities, die sehr, sehr einverdreichend kreativ sind. Und ich denke mal, dass das einfach auch in Zukunft wichtig sein wird, auch auf diese Fans zu hören, weil das sehr, sehr aktive und sehr loyale Fans sind.
Was werdet ihr als nächstes für eine Fan-Fiction schreiben? Oh Gott, in dieser Sendung, in der ich sozusagen ein und das andere Mal das Auge und die Auge auch mal verwundert war, jetzt hättet ihr gerade Henrys Gesicht sehen sollen. Als ich nach seiner Fan-Fiction, die er noch schreiben wird, gefragt hab.
Ich bin da so wenig der Schreiber. Also wenn ich schreibe, sind es mehr Programme, glaube ich.
Also Markus schreibt jetzt als nächstes was über Mutantenponys. Klar, warten wir alle drauf. Sefa hat uns ja jetzt schon Links gegeben. Die hab ich jetzt auch alle gerade mal in den Twitter getan. Mein Twitter nick ist tweener. Diese Links, da geht's dann schon mal um Mutantenponys. Da hat jemand diese Plastikponys nämlich genommen und mit so Knete und Fimo zu Mutantenponys verarbeitet. Auch ein ganz interessanter Beitrag zur Fan-Kultur.
Okay, super. Haben wir uns auch noch Mutantenponys umgebracht. So, wir haben jetzt noch einen Anrufer, den nehmen wir noch ganz kurz rein und dann ist auch gleich Schluss.
Marc?
Als letzter Anrufer-Fan?
Ja, richtig. Und zwar habe ich mich dazu geschaltet, weil ich, also ich bin jetzt gerade erst dazugekommen, auch zum Stream vom Radio und ich wollte im Endeffekt wissen, also beziehungsweise wollte ich gerade noch das Thema übergreifend sagen, was jetzt Massive-Multiplayer-Online-Games betrifft. Ich persönlich bin momentan mit einem amerikanischen Team am Arbeiten und arbeite dort momentan als freiberuflicher Designer, sage ich jetzt mal. Und wir bereiten momentan für die große BronyCon, die jetzt in zwei Monaten circa läuft, ein Multiplayer-Online-Spiel vor, ein 2D. Das Ganze nennt sich MLP Online, endefektlich. Und dort soll man dann, wie man das kennt, Quests lösen. Man kriegt Events, es gibt eine Art Kampfsystem, was sich ziemlich an alte Final Fantasy Teile ansiedelt. Also sowas ist auf jeden Fall das, was ich mache.
Ein Online-Rollenspiel im My Little Pony-Universum, ist das offiziell oder ist das auch eine Fanart?
Das ist momentan eine fan-based Sache, die wird aber offiziell mit Stand auf der BronyCon halt aufgeführt und vorgestellt. Und wir versuchen dann im Endeffekt mit diesem Produkt und diesem Spiel verschiedene, nicht nur die Leute in der Szene, sprich die Brony, sondern auch wirklich Leute außerhalb, also ein bisschen dem Thema näherzubringen. Und das halt dann auf die spielerische Weise.
Um Gottes Willen, jetzt gibt es auch noch ein Online-Rollenspiel. Sag mal kurz noch den Namen.
Das Game wird MLP Online heißen. Da gibt es auch eine Gruppe zu und eine Homepage mit vorhandenem Trailer.
Okay, Marc, weil die Zeit schon knapp ist, könntest du uns auch einen Gefallen tun und das ins Wiki zur Sendung schreiben.
Noch ganz kurz danke Marc, dass er uns dran erinnert hat. Es gibt natürlich auch Cons dazu mit Leuten, die sich dann im Reallife treffen und ganz groß wie bei vielen anderen Dingen. Damit haben wir dann den Kreis zur Hackerkultur wieder geschlossen. Es gibt Cons, wo sich Leute in der realen Welt treffen und es gibt halt diesen Community-Zusammenhalt und Leute helfen sich gegeneinander, wie auch in der Hackerkultur.
So, wir haben jetzt gleich noch ein kleines Schmanker für euch. Ich bin ja eigentlich zwei kleine Schmanker, denn es gibt in diesem Bereich Fanarbeit. Natürlich auch Leute, die sich mit der Musik von den Ponys beschäftigt haben. Und da hab ich noch einen kleinen Track gefunden, da ist... Wie heißt das? Pinkie? Okay, Party with Pinkie Pie heißt der Track von LXS. Ich find den super.
Genau, das spaltet sich sehr.
Und bevor wir dazu kommen, verabschiede ich mich. Sag recht herzlichen Dank Henrik fürs Expertentum.
Ja, bitte.
Und Tina für die Einblicke in die Fanfiction. Und du hast jetzt noch ganz zum Schluss für alle Fans, bevor wir den Nightfight mit Flo Heiler und die Punk-Musik abgeben, ein kleines bisschen Horror.
Du darfst es jetzt nicht sparen.
Mann ey, das war so eine gute Einleitung. Okay, warte, wir müssen nochmal. Ich komm einfach nochmal rein.
Ja, bitte.
Und dann hast du noch ganz zum Schluss so ein kleines bisschen Horror.
She looked into his eyes and his heart fluttered slightly. Call me Rarity, came the whisper, before her lips pressed against his. It only lasted for a few seconds, but those few seconds were some of the best in his life. Her pillow-soft and lipstick-covered lips pulled away from his heart wind-chopped once, opening her massive deep blue eyes and staring up in his still shocked expression. Grinning deviously, as it quickly changed from shock to acceptance, he had clearly wanted this for a while.